vielleicht spiele ich für viele menschen
ein fester bestandteil ihres lebens und
gerade in den letzten jahren besonders
bei der jugend sehr sehr berühmt
geworden nachdem ich den doku von einer
person gesehen habe sie behauptet hat
dass die hauptberuflich poker spielt
kamen mir eine frage wie schwer ist es
professionell politik
[Musik]
dass man so wie das in den letzten zwei
monaten so wenig kam ich habe einfach
viel gekifft und ja das stimmt 100
prozent denn ich habe eine doku mit
einem selbstversuch zum thema cannabis
gedreht die doku komplexe woche sonntag
vergessen ist den kanal zu abonnieren
damit wir das nicht erfasst ich empfehle
ich niemanden egal welche art von
glücksspiel laster komplett die finger
davon wenn ihr die finger nicht darum
gelassen habt und zum spielen seit
findet ihr über den ersten link in der
video beschreibung einen hilfe link
könnt ihr euch hilfe holen und kommt
hoffentlich sehr schnell von der
spielsucht wenn das ist die größte
chance aber genau dafür bin ich ja damit
ihr das nicht selber ausprobieren müsst
und ich so hoffentlich alle offenen
fragen klären und natürlich damit den
sieben tagen fällig werden zwar hat die
bank bei automaten immer gewinnt weil
man absolut keinen einfluss auf das
spielgeschehen haben sollte jedem klar
sein es gibt aber natürlich auch andere
arten von glücksspiel wie sportwetten
oder poker bei denen man durch seine
eigenen entscheidungen einfluss auf das
ergebnis nimmt und dadurch gibt es auch
leute die das hauptberuflich machen
finden also es gibt leute die
hauptberuflich bevor ich jetzt anfangen
in den nächsten sieben tagen jeden tag
acht stunden poker zu spielen wie bei
einem normalen hauptberuf erkläre ich
euch erstmal das grundkonzept von poker
dem extrem vereinfacht ein grundkonzept
erhält jeder spieler verdeckt zwei
karten ziel ist es im laufe der runde
mit später offen gezeigten karten eine
möglichst wertige karten kombination zu
erreichen zwischen dem austeilen der
ersten karten und dem stück weise zeigen
der offenen karten hat jeder spieler die
möglichkeit chips welche die währung im
spiel sind auf seine hand zu setzen oder
die runde zu verlassen am ende gewinnt
die haben mit dem höchsten berg dieser
erklärung des extrem vereinfacht und es
gibt sehr viele verschiedene arten von
eine erklärung für die am weitesten
verbreitete art namens texas hold'em
findet ihr in der video beschrieben in
den ersten vier tagen werde ich komplett
ohne geld spielen weil ich überhaupt
keine ahnung habe und in meinem leben
noch nie wirklich poker gespielt habe in
den drei danach folgenden tagen werde
ich online um geld spielen und am
allerletzten tag gehe ich ins casino und
spiele bei einem turnier mit der zeit
erstmal spielen spielen spielen damit
ich möglichst viele erfahrungen sammeln
kann ohne dabei eine menge geld zufall
hier etwas machen
tag eins ich habe extrem ist wenig
gefühl dafür bei welchen karte nicht mit
gehen soll und bei welchen nicht
irgendwie denke ich dass meine gegner
wissen was ich für karten auf meiner
hand hat während ich überhaupt keine
ahnung habe was sie auf ihrer hand haben
können aus diesem grund habe ich mir
quasi direkt hilfe von einem kumpel
geholt welcher schon mehrere jahre
erfahrung im poker hat der spiele
parallel auch turniere und stream er
seinen bildschirm über die scort so dass
ich mir seinen bissigen making und vor
allem seinen spielstil abschauen kann
außerdem dauern die runden deutlich
länger als gedacht habe und ich sitze
manchmal über eine stunde in einem
weil ihr die zeit völlig aus den augen
plötzlich ist es schon 1 und 8 und ich
finde mich am final table eines turniers
mit circa 50 mitspieler eine weitere
stunde später beende ich meinen ersten
poker tag mit einem turniersieg festtag
nummer zwei durch meinen gestrigen sieg
bin ich schon geist krankheit und freue
mich schon den ganzen tag aufspielen
let's go mein kontostand ist von
anfänglichen 5 millionen auf 6 millionen
gestiegen und ich plane natürlich den
heute weiter auszubauen damit ich
doppelt oder dreifach so viel erfahrung
sammeln kann werde ich mich bei mehreren
turnieren gleichzeitig an sieht schon
mal professionell aus nach anfänglichen
startschwierigkeiten obwohl ich ja ich
bin richtig so loos liefers dann
eigentlich relativ schnell sehr sehr gut
ist let's go das war es geht hier
richtig bergauf alter da manha
außerdem hatte ich schon echt das gefühl
so ein bisschen poker linke übernommen
zu haben
so soll ich denen er vom lindenhof die
limits haben sich erhöht lahm foult
licht ist also weil hier oben bin ich
zwei vor der bubble halt ne kinohit und
außerdem habe ich mich meinem bis dato
größten turniers eine absolut
aussichtslosen situationen heraus
gekämpft ich bin wieder back in game
brot ich habe in diesem turnier alleine
mehr gewonnen als sich komplett auf
meinem pokerstars konto abging 900 yes
yes mein gott platz 17
ich bin noch in der neuen stufe wir
haben 93 millionen us und montana als
profilbild besser kann es nicht laufen
bei per stick duo am sonntag hier sind
mittlerweile auch schon rum ihr habt
davon relativ wenig mitbekommen im
vergleich zu tag eins und zwei denn es
lief nicht ganz so gut wie in den ersten
beiden tagen
ich kann nichts machen so schlecht lief
es gar nicht also ich hab zwar kennt
hier gewonnen die am ersten tag oder
nicht sofort abgesetzt wie im zweiten
aber ich bin zumindest auf einem level
gewinn und hat nach wie vor über neun
millionen chips was das doppelte ist von
dem und bin ich angefangen habe heute
startet zwar wie geplant meine
pokerkarriere mit echtem geld zumindest
erstmal online es gibt aber sehr
schlechte nachrichten ich habe jedes
spiel man kennt nrw ab telefoniert um
herausfinden in welcher noch turniere
gespielt werden aufgrund von corona in
keiner perfekt dabei in nrw wieder
treffen von bis zu zehn leuten erlaubt
sind und ein pokertisch aus neun
spielern und einem kopierer besteht
werde ich in den nächsten zwei tagen
parallel zum poker online spielen
probieren einen coupé und acht weitere
mitspieler zu finden die bereit sind mit
mir zu zocken
ich werde definitiv an der idee
festhalten am letzten tag das projekt
ist ein reallife game zu spielen weil
das natürlich das finale das große
finale des experimentes ist das hat aber
natürlich nicht ohne sorge sein deswegen
starten wir jetzt mittag vom festgeld
online so tag nochmal 50 100 euro
überwiesen das mit 109 dollar let's go
ich habe mir extra das t shirt angezogen
mit dem ich am zweiten tag so fett
gewonnen habe freute wie deaktiviert ich
werde mich ganz gut aus der zukunft das
video war wieder eine menge arbeiten
wenn ihr mich unterstützen wollten
lassen like darf vielen dank das
pokerspiel hat mir so viel spaß gemacht
dass sie überlegt habe einen
pokerturniere mit youtube zu machen wo
geld für charity gesammelt da gab es
schon mal so was dass sich let's play
pokal irgendwas in die richtung wenn du
also youtube ist los dass poker zu
spielen dann möchte ich bei mir bei
instagram und vielleicht kriegen wir
irgendwas zusammen
das ist natürlich jetzt erstmal nur eine
idee wenn wir aber ein paar leute
zusammenbekommen dann könnte das glaube
ich ziemlich glücklich aber also musste
ich das ganze nicht alleine durchstehen
sondern hat ja die ganze zeit monte an
meiner seite und der war schon ziemlich
hart
[Musik]
68 oh mein gott oh mein gott
man muss nicht alles verstehen nämlich
habe ich genau diese hand gezeigt weil
die ziemlich passend für den kompletten
tag 5 steht denn es hat rein gar nichts
funktionieren ich habe wirklich gottlos
schlecht gespielt was dazu geführt hat
dass ich dachte 5 mit einem minus von 15
dollar gehandelt haben ja ich werde euch
hier nicht die ganze zeit irgendwelche
hände zeigen denn das juckt wirklich
niemanden falls es euch doch jürgen
sollte habe ich meine kompletten screen
rekords auf nicht gelistet hochgeladen
damit ihr euch das anschauen könnt so
tag 6 ich hoffe dass es heute ein wenig
besser funktioniert als gestern an tag 5
weil sonst habe ich gleich kein geld
mehr auf lukas kommt und junge das hat
uns neben mehreren guten platzierungen 2
dollar 50 turnieren mit 180 teilnehmern
welche meistens gespielt habe habe ich
auch eine top 30 platzierung in einem 11
dollar turnier geholt was über 30 dollar
gebracht hat dadurch verändert ich tag
sex mit einem plus von 2 euro zum sache
und das ist an dieser situation mega
verrückt man gewinnt an dem abend mega
viel badet damit aber natürlich zuerst
die negativen ergebnisse vom vorabend
aus da hat man das gefühl an dem abend
mega viel gewonnen zu haben obwohl es
quasi nur der umsatz war und der gewinn
ist marginal vom original der gewinn ist
relativ gering am siebten und damit
letzten tag kam es dann wie es kommen
musste ich habe hier immer viele tische
gleichzeitig gespielt bei den meisten
habe ich meinen einsatz wieder bekommen
aber nichts wirklich gewonnen bis ich
mich dann plötzlich am final table 12
dollar 50 trainiert wieder finden nach
und nach liegen immer weiter leute raus
bis sich mit einer sehr guten hand
nahezu alle meine chips verliere und ich
das turnier auf dem dritten platz
beendet und so ein wenig mehr als 30
dollar
ach ja und außerdem haben sich noch
munter und klose getroffen der war eklig
bevor wir uns jetzt ankommt und was im
großen finale dem reallife turnier
passiert ist einmal kurzen fazit zum
online zum insgesamt 56 turniere
gespielt und insgesamt 272 dollar
umgesetzt sieht man die beiden turniere
ab bleiben 132 euro ich hatte ja 100
euro eingezahlt das bedeutet wir haben
32 euro reingewinn
das wirklich verrückt weil wir haben 272
dollar umgesetzt das bedeutet ich habe
insgesamt 272 dollar gewonnen
davon bleibt aber quasi nichts übrig
weil wir uns hier einkaufen müssen uns
so weiter also das gefühl ist ein ganz
anderes als das was im endeffekt
wirklich darum kommt und das ist negativ
werden durchschnittlich habe ich die
turniere auf platz 30 beendet das hört
sich erstmal nicht so mega chaos an sind
aber die top 17 prozent und ich glaube
für die erste woche poker kann man das
schon als riesenerfolg mein größter
gewinnen waren 65 dollar 11 euro turnier
und mein größter verlust waren 7 euro 50
weil ich in 7 euro 50 turniere nichts
gewonnen und jetzt schauen wir uns an
was am großen finale live poker passiert
ist für den letzten abend habe ich dann
tatsächlich geschafft einen pokertisch
und acht leute zu organisieren einer
dieser acht personen war mein trainer
der mich durch die online zeit begleitet
hat nachdem er innerhalb von fünf
stunden personen für personen vom tisch
gehauen haben lassen wir nur noch zu
zweit
mittlerweile war es schon weit nach 0
uhr wir hatten ziemlich genau gleich
viele chips und er hat mich komplett
zerstört ich habe mit us kollegen
gecallt er hatte zwei erste und damit
war die runde beendet ich also auf dem
zweiten platz mein trainer auf dem
ersten das zeigt deutlich dass
erfahrungen training und disziplin
komplett überlegen sind okay sieben
beziehungsweise acht tage pokern sind
vorbei es hat unfassbar viel spaß
gemacht ich kann nicht wirklich nicht
daran erinnern wann ich das letzte mal
bei irgendwas wird sich neu gemacht habe
so viel spaß hatte das liegt natürlich
auch daran dass ich ein positives
ergebnis hat und mit plus rausgehe und
schöne turniere gehabt habe werde das
jetzt nicht so gewesen hätte ich
wahrscheinlich eine relativ negative
einstellung und ich glaube genau hier
liegt die gefahr wenn positiv läuft
denkt man muss überlegen
kann das die ganze zeit reduzieren und
dann einfach die ganze zeit gewinnen
damit ist aber schlecht läuft hat man
wahrscheinlich das gefühl dass man es
nur durch weitere turniere ausgleichen
kann damit man eben großen pots gewinnt
und irgendwie mit plus kosten in beide
richtungen irgendwie so in eine sucht
gezogen wird und ich habe das recht nach
einer woche schon bei mir gemerkt weil
es einfach so viel spaß gemacht hat was
ich am liebsten die ganze arbeit und
wollte spielen sollen poker ist und
bleibt eben eine art von glücksspiel
auch wenn man es gar nicht mit roulette
oder automatenspielen diverse vergleiche
der sieg meines trainers über mich am
letzten abend hat mir auch deutlich
gezeigt dass man nicht einfach
leichtfertig denken darf man sein mega
guter spieler es gibt wahrscheinlich
immerhin der beste oder vielleicht auch
einfach in irgendeiner situation der
glück hatte und jahr trotz alledem gibt
es leute die das hauptberuflich und
professionell machen aber auf diesem weg
dahin bleiben unzählige menschen auf der
strecke und man sieht halt eben nur die
die es wirklich im endeffekt schaffen
und professionell spielt eine feder holz
der mit mitte zwanzig irgendwie 40
millionen euro mit burka verdient hat
bei einem turnier zuzuschauen macht mir
spaß und das verstehe ich erst seit
dieser nacht also mittlerweile kann ich
die begeisterung für poker voll und ganz
nachvollziehen das macht es aber nicht
geben könnte es bei diesen leuten die
komplett an der spitze stehen kann man
eben auch nicht runter sprechen dass sie
nur durch absolute disziplin training
und erfahrung genau da sind wo sie sind
natürlich haben dann einzeln der hände
die die spiele noch mal mit glück zu tun
aber man gewinnt nicht drei jahre lang
jedes turnier mit glück muss aber auch
noch mal ausdrücklich sagen in sieben
tagen professionell poker zu spielen
das wird nicht funktionieren das ist ein
langjähriger prozess man muss unendlich
viele hände spielen es gibt so was das
heißt variance das bedeutet dass man
einfach manche hände spielen muss und
die mich immer treffen und über die zeit
gleicht sich das halt einfach auf jeden
fall hat in der rehab pokerabend gezeigt
dass ich definitiv in folge video machen
will indem ich in einem richtigen casino
und ein richtiges turnier spielt echte
menschen vor sich sitzen zu haben und
die möglichkeit zu haben die lesen zu
können bringt einfach nochmal so viel
mehr in dieses spiel rein als es nur
online zu machen das ist einfach wie
eine dimension nicht an ihr schon länger
mit echtem geld spielt und ihr
langfristig verliert oder euch
vorgaukelt zu gewinnen dann holt euch
hilft links in der video bestanden
vielen dank fürs zuschauen vergesst
nicht zu abonnieren damit in der
nächsten woche beim kiffen zuschauen
können lassen leichter wenn es euch
gefallen hat macht gut